قال موظف سابق في تويتر انه توجد امكانيه
كبيره لحدوث انقطاع كبير في موقع تويتر
اثناء بطوله كاس العالم التي تنطلق غدا في
قطر الامر الذي يمكن ان يؤدي لخروج تويتر
عن الخدمه الموظف السابق الذي طلب عدم
الكشف عن هويته قال انه بين الافتقار الى
الاستعدادات والاقص الموظفين فان كاس
العالم ستكون صعبه بالنسبه لمنصه تويتر
اشار المتحدث نفسه الى ان حديثه من نوع ما
مثل استجابه خدمه بطيئه او غير صحيحه تكاد
تكون مؤكده خلال المنافسه التي ستستمر
لمده شهر في قطر
هذا هو نقلت فرانسبريس عن مدير في تويتر
قوله ان الرؤيه ضبابيه جدا في الشركه وان
العاصفه قادمه على حد تعبيره وهذا بعد
تسريح اكثر من نصف موظفي وتر واستقالتي
مئات اخرين المدير في تويتر كلوز قال انه
لم يبقى سوى ثلاثه مهندسين من اصل 75
كانوا في فريقه وشاركلوز الى ان الى
الماسك لم يقدم خطه خماسيه مثل ما فعل في
شركه تسلا معتبرا ان ما يفعله ماسك مجرد
اختبار ولاء واكد المدير في تويتر انه
غادر منصه لانه لن يضحي من اجل وعود غامضه
على حد قوله
معنى من سان فرانسيسكو ومن امام المقرئيس
لشركه تويوتا المراسل العربيه حسين الطود
حسين هل تكشفت معلومات اضافيه عن اعداد
الموظفين المستقلين من تويتر
صهيب حتى الان العدد الذي عرفنا به الذي
استقال البارحه تقريبا هو 11 موظف هو عدد
كبير في الحقيقه في ظل اقتراب كاس العالم
وفي ظل المخاوف تزايد المخاوف من حدوث
انقطاع خلال ايام القادمه خاصه خلال كاس
العالم همم نظام همم تويتر صهيب نظام معقد
يتطلب عدد كبير من التقنيين للحفاظ على
استمريته ابن انسيابيه الان همم كما قال
الخبير وكما يقول خبراء اخرون حتى من خارج
تويتر الموضوع ليس سهل هم العديد منهم
يقولون ان انا قد لا نشهد همم القطاع همم
بشكل مباشر او قطاعا اا ظاهرا ولكن ستكون
هناك بطباطئ بالخدمه عندما همم رفع
الافلام او تنزيل الافلام او همم موسوعه
تايم لاين كل هذا الامور المرشحه بقوه لكي
تحدث
الان قبل قليل كنا هنا في همم المبنى
وراينا عدد من الاشخاص يدخلون اليه حا
اللحاق بهم لنسالهم ان كانوا موظفين ام لا
ولكن ال- ال- الامن همم التابع للشركه
ونتابع للمبنى منعنا وطلب منا التراجع الى
الخلف والبقاء خارج همم المحيط محيط
المبنى حيث نحن الان حسين وانت تريد
المقر الرئيسي لشركه تويتر اريد ان اسالك
عن معلومه كذلك كان هناك خبر يتحدث على
انه ماسك منع دخول الموظفين الى هذا المقر
الرئيسي الذي نشاهده الان على المباشر حتى
يوم الاثنين همم لماذا حسين هلا هلا شرحت
لنا طبيعه القرارات التي اتخذها الى
الماسك
هناك تخوف حسب ما فهمنا من قلهم ماسك ومن
العدد من المسؤولين بان يقوم
هدوء هؤلاء الاشخاص بالقيام باعمال
تخريبيه داخل
المؤسسه لذلك هو قال انه منعوا ولكن كان
هناك
مفارقه انه في لا يفصل وقت طلب البارحه
يوم الجمعه
بمن يجيد البرمجه كتابه البرامج السوفت
ويرز بالفعل اشترى معهم ونشر الصوره رغم
انهم كانوا ممنوعين من الدخول الى همم
مبنى التويتر الذي نشاهدها امامنا كما قلت
هناك كان همم قرار مصر بانه تخوف من
القيام باعمال تخريبيه لممتلكات الشركه من
قبل الموظفين اما ال- ال- المفصولين او
الذين اختاروا
يستقيل وهم عدد كبير كمان همم ذكرنا سابقا
نحن لا نتجه باتجاه المدخل الرئيسي همم
لنريكم اين همم منعنا ال- ال- الحراس
الاميون لم يسمح لنا بالدخول في الصباح
عندما تنهى في ساعات الصباح الاولى سمح
لنا بالدخول الان عندما اتى الموظفون او
الاشخاص الذين نعتقد انهم موظفون عندما
دخلوا ودخلنا خلفهم يسالهم تم منعنا وتلما
طلب منا البقاء في الخارج لان ذلك قالوا
لنا هذه ملكيه خاصه ولا يحق لكم التواجد
همم فيها همم لا نعرف عود واقرر صهيب لست
متاكد ان كان هؤلاء موظفين ام لا همم
سننتظرهم طبعا حتى ان خرجوا من هناك من
المبنى طيب هذا هو همم
الرئيسي الاول هذا هو المبنى هناك عند تلك
القارمه همم
الحمراء هناك هناك المدخل الرئيسي لشركه
تويتر ولكن ممنوعه ندخل الى الان داخل
ساعات الصباح الاولى حيث
في في الشركه وعملاق التواصل الاجتماعي
تويتر ااا الى الماسك بعد استحوذه على
تويتر صرح نصف الموظفين همم والان كما
ذكرت عدد المستقلين بلغ 1200 موظف فقدم
استقالاتهم ااه لماذا ما الاسباب لان له
الماسك طلب منهم ان يعملوا عملا مضاعفا
ساعات اضافيه ام لماذا استقاله
هذا هذا سبب رئيسي طلب منهم العمل لساعات
طويله العمل
بكثره همم موضوع العمل عن بعد عن العمل من
المنزل ايضا لاعبه دورا هو هو طالب العديد
منهم بالطلبهم بالقدوم الى المراكز
الرئيسيه هنا في سان فرانسيسكو في المراكز
الاخرى حول العالم همم هذا اثر كثيرا طبعا
هناك ايضا الخلاف حول رؤيه همم لهم ما كان
موظفوا يرفضون رؤيته يرفضون همم
السياسات الجديده المتعلقه بالمحتوى لهم
ماسك يشدد على انه مع حريه التعبير ويقول
همم
يبرر ذلك بانه لم يسمح همم خطاب الكراهيه
واي تغريده همم
خطاب كراهيه لن يسمح بالترويج لها ولكنه
لم يمنعها هذا مرر ما قال له ولكن في
المقابل الكثيرون يرفضون هناك هكذا سياسات
ويقولون انها تشجع على خطاب الكراهيه
ونسكر ان مؤسسات همم
نظمات على المجتمع المدني والمدافع عن
الحقوق طالبت الشركات الكبرى في الولايات
المتحده عدد بعدم الاستثمار بالاعلانات
بهذه الشركه طالما ان هناك همم ترويج
لخطاب الكرايه حسب ما مر لهم ذلك لهم ماسك
يؤكد دائما انه لا يروج الخطاب القرار هو
لكن هو يريد النقطه حسين يعني اخر تغيير
على متابعيها على تويتر ان كان يجب اعاده
تفعيل حساب دونالد ترامب همم الذي ابعد عن
تويتر في ظل الاداره ال- ال- السابقه همم
كيف ينظر الى الى هذا الموضوع كذلك
وربما علاقته بهذه الاستقالات
ااا طبعا ااا بالنسبه للدونالد ترامب تم
الغاء حسابي او تم ااا وضع حظر على حسابه
بعد اا فوز جو بايدن همم وبعد 11 احداث
السادس من يناير ولكن بالنسبه لهم ماسك
اساسا هو طالبه وقال له انه مرحب بها ان
يعود اول مره ثم قرر انه
سيلتزم همم بالقرار التصويت الذي وضعه
الان هناك التصويت على تويتر ليرى همم من
يريدون ان يعود ترامب هو له علاقه جيده
بالترامب ترامب كان اعتذر من همم
[موسيقى]
اشكرك
همم
شكرا جزيلا لك اذا همم نبقى في المتابعه
معك باي اخبار ترشحدا عدد الموظفين حتى
الان همم 1200 موظف همم شكرا جزيلا لك على
هذا التحديث حسين الطود مباشره من امام
المقر الرئيسي لشركه تويتر في سان
فرانسيسكو